es momento de repasar la prensa
internacional ya nos acompaña en el
estudio martamoya bienvenida Hola Rosa
Buenos días Marta y hoy no podríamos
arrancar dedicar esta sección a otra
noticia Que no sea la muerte de Silvio
berlusconi no Así es vamos a empezar
rosa con la prensa italiana
concretamente empezamos por el correr de
la acera un medio de Milán de la ciudad
natal de berlusconi que titula este
lunes muere Silvio berlusconi a los 86
años y el cavaliere ha fallecido a las
9:30 en el hospital San Rafael de Milano
y
reingresó el viernes a este hospital
después de una larga hospitalización
anterior que duró 45 días a razón de una
neumonía y de la leucemia que ya
arrastraba IL cavaliere ahora no se
descarta que se habilite el duomo de
Milán para su funeral y además el
tanatorio podría darse en las
inmediaciones de que es el conglomerados
el conglomerado de medios del que él es
presidente y Corea de la cera dice
además textualmente berlusconi fue un
fenómeno lleno de voluntad de poder por
supuesto pero también de necesidad
histórica no era un santo tenía sus
vicios privados públicos y sabía jugar
sucio por otro lado hemos destacado la
república que titula fin de una era con
la muerte de berlusconi acaba un trozo
de la historia italiana eso dice la
República romana que dice además que va
a ser difícil imaginar a una Italia sin
Silvio berlusconi además textualmente
sostiene la república que en los últimos
50 años no ha habido un solo día en que
en que no se mencionara su nombre tanto
en la televisión como en el parlamento
como en los periódicos como en los
estadios de fútbol Incluso en los bares
recordemos que berlusconi además de
presidente de mediase fue presidente y
fundador del AC Milan y también después
del Monza que es una ciudad a pocos
kilómetros de Milán además fue germen
también del movimiento Forza Italia
exactamente y recordemos lo estábamos
viendo antes en la redacción su pastel
de su último cumpleaños no en que cada
piso de ese pastel incluía una de las
organizaciones una de las empresas que
tenía este Magnate no Y si finalmente el
funeral tiene lugar en las inmediaciones
de mediasettia la Extravaganza hasta un
poco hasta el final no de esos días
efectivamente podría definir de otra
manera además dice la república que para
bien o para mal era el espejo de nuestro
extraño país sí siempre también Marta me
sorprende lo primero que comentabas del
curriere de la seda cuando dicen tenía
sus luces y sus sombras no siempre estos
equilibrios para hablar de Finalmente
acusaciones muy graves no contra el
mandatario sin ir más lejos abuso abuso
de menores bueno
hemos destacado también Rosa pero la
estampa también italiana que titula este
lunes Adiós Cavalier dice en la estampa
que entre otras cosas ver luzcón y creó
un imperio televisivo que moldeó el
imaginario italiano por dos décadas
además en este artículo repasa un poco
las aquejaciones de salud que tuvo el
cavaliere a lo largo de su vida a
finales de los 90 extirparon un tumor de
próstata luego en 2009 fue hospitalizado
por un ataque al corazón tras un
atentado en la piazza del duomo en
Milano también tuvo problemas
intestinales de vistas Y bueno pues el
desenlace fatal por esta leucemia que ya
acarreaba Y por último hemos destacado
ilfato cotidiano también italiano que
titula ha muerto Silvio berlusconi el
primero de los populistas plusmarquista
en investigaciones de la corrupción
hasta la mafia y mago de la comunicación
dice a su manera ha creado una escuela
en el mundo de sus asombrosas promesas
poco queda mientras el mundo daba
vueltas entre revoluciones tecnológicas
y nuevos escenarios globales Italia se
quedó envuelta discutiendo sobre él sus
intereses económicos y sus problemas
judiciales eso dice el pato cotidiano
pues Marta pasemos a las portadas
europeas las portadas web no porque esta
noticia ha llegado Cuando ya las
rotativas en papel habían sido
imprimidas hacía rato en Europa Sí Rosa
vamos a destacar cuatro cabeceras
europeas Aunque la noticia por supuesto
está en todos los medios del mundo hemos
destacado en primer lugar Liberación que
titula muere Silvio berlusconi y
cavaliere deja la pista dice Liberación
que incluso para sus más fieles
adversarios berlusconi se había
convertido en una suerte de figura casi
inmortal que tuvo durante muchos años el
monopolio de la escena pública italiana
Por otra parte hemos destacado el
británico de Garden que dice que fue un
tipo envuelto en escándalos uno de los
políticos también más extravagantes de
Italia que había regresado a la primera
línea política en 2017 a pesar de sus
investigaciones por delitos sexuales
como comentábamos también sus
innumerables acusaciones de corrupción y
una condena la única condena por fraude
fiscal Por otra parte hemos destacado el
diario.es de España que nos habla de que
El Magnate cambió la forma de hacer
política en Italia dice el diario punto
es que es una suerte de Donald Trump
bajito y Moreno nacido mucho antes del
trampismo y que creó una forma de hacer
política en torno a su persona además un
dato curioso Y es que berlusconi llamó a
los máximos dirigentes de Forza Italia
este mismo fin de semana a reunirse en
su mansión en el norte de Milán un
encuentro que no se pudo dar y que ahora
siembra el interrogante de A dónde puede
ir Forza Italia atrás la muerte de
Silvio verlos con Y por último hemos
destacado de spigger que dice que él
mismo se definió una vez como el
Jesucristo de la política y que no solo
Tuvo una vida pública plagada de
escándalos sino que también tuvo
escándalos en el seno de su vida privada
dice que se divorció dos veces que deja
cinco hijos y un montón de nietos eso
dice despiggle Marta y rápidamente que
nos dice la galleta del sur de este
imperio económico de verlos con y como
usted decía el Trump antes que Trump
Pues sí Rosa la gaceta del sud nos habla
de las mil vidas de Silvio berlusconi un
empresario de éxito desde el plano
inmobiliario donde empezó a gestar ese
imperio económico luego Magnate de la
televisión privada en Italia y después
en su entrada política en 1994 su primer
ladrillo lo puso con 27 años que fue el
germen de ese imperio después en 1998
creó fininves que es un holding que
coordina todas sus actividades
empresariales después se metió en el
Imperio de la televisión creo mediaset
Italia que luego se extrapoló a España
un dato es que las acciones de mediaset
han subido tras la muerte de Silvio
berlusconi Y que ahora la figura del
presidente de la corporación están entre
dicho tras su muerte y que después ya
por finalizar en 1986 fundó el ac Milán
y después del Monza que lo acabó de
configurar como un Magnate a todas las
escalas en Italia pues Marta llegamos
así al final de revista de prensa Pero
le pido que se quede en el estudio
aprovechando su conocimiento de la
política italiana para abordar
precisamente que supone la muerte de
este Magnate de este político para el
panorama político Precisamente en Italia